bienvenidos de nuevo Hoy es un día
bastante bastante bonito para hacer
vídeos del SAT Así que empecemos estamos
en la sección número 4 del examen número
4 y voy a empezar con el problema número
12 el problema número 12 que dice lo
siguiente el perímetro de un terreno
rectangular es de 250 metros déjame
apuntarlo el perímetro es
250 metros perfecto si la longitud de
uno de sus lados del terreno es de 40
metros Cuál es el área del terreno Wow
este problema Está fascinante me gusta
bastante fíjate bien Vamos a dibujar
aquí el terreno es un terreno
rectangular Así que vamos a dibujarlo
más o menos así Este es mi terreno y me
dicen que el valor de uno de sus lados
es de 40 metros Así que voy a suponer
que este lado vale 40 metros 40 metros
lo padre de estos que si este lado vale
40 metros este lado también vale 40
metros este lado también vale 40 metros
Y cuánto vale el otro Bueno pues no lo
sabemos pero supongamos que le ponemos
el nombre de X este lado vale x y lo
padre es que si este lado vale x
entonces este lado también va a valer x
por lo tanto como podemos expresar el
perímetro dado estos cuatro datos Cómo
podemos expresar el perímetro utilizando
esta información de aquí Bueno pues el
perímetro es este más este es decir 80
80 más este más este x + x Me quedaría
2x 80 + 2x bueno Esto es lo que es el
perímetro utilizando estos datos sin
embargo por otra parte me dicen que el
perímetro es igual a 250 metros por lo
tanto eso tiene que ser igual a
250 metros y de aquí podemos despejar a
x me va a quedar que 2x es igual a 250
menos 80 y esto es igual a 200 170 a 170
Perfecto 2x es igual a 170 y ahora si
divido entre 2 entre 2 y entre 2 me va a
quedar que x es decir la longitud de
este lado es igual a 170 entre 2 lo cual
es a 85 85 metros por lo tanto ya
sabemos que este lado mide 85 metros y
este también va a valer 85 metros
perfecto ya tenemos cuánto vale cada uno
de los lados de este terreno rectangular
y por lo tanto si queremos sacar el área
pues lo podemos sacar utilizando la
fórmula de base por altura está muy
fácil el área de este terreno
rectangular es igual a la base que vale
85 metros 85 por la altura pero la
altura son 40 metros Y cuánto es esto
ponemos un cero aquí y me queda 5 por 4
es 20 y llevamos 2
4 por 8 32 y 234 34
3.400 metros cuadrados
3.400 metros cuadrados es el área de
esta figura de este terreno rectangular
que tenemos aquí
3.400 metros cuadrados así que ya está
ya tenemos el problema número 12 y vamos
a resolver el problema número 13 y para
Esto
va muy bien las matemáticas creo que sí
vamos a borrar la pantalla entonces
perfecto borramos la pantalla y ahora
vamos a hacer el problema número 13 Qué
dice una escuela ordena 600 pesos en
focos para sus instalaciones
600 pesos en focos Déjenme apuntarlo
aquí 600 pesos en focos muy bien por
mayoreo algunos de los focos valen un
peso cada uno y otro tipo de focos valen
2 pesos cada uno así que tenemos dos
tipos de focos los que valen un peso los
que valen un peso y los que valen 2
pesos los que salen dos pesos si se
compraron el doble de focos del valor de
un peso que los que valen 2 pesos Guau
eso Está increíble si se compraron el
doble de focos del valor de un peso que
de los que valen 2 pesos Cuántos focos
en total se compraron Cuántos focos en
total se compraron vamos a escribirlo
Así supongamos que x es la cantidad de
focos que compramos del valor de 2 pesos
entonces es la cantidad de focos de
focos que valen 2 pesos que valen valen
a 2 pesos valen 2 pesos Ok si x es la
cantidad de focos que valen 2 pesos para
no meter unas para no escribir una nueva
variable en problema Cómo podemos
expresar la cantidad de focos que valen
un peso Si Nosotros sabemos que tenemos
x focos que valen 2 pesos es decir Cómo
podemos escribir la cantidad de focos de
focos que valen un peso que valen un
peso Bueno lo que nos dice el problema
es que se compraron el doble de focos
que valen un peso el doble de focos que
vayan en un peso a comparación de la
cantidad de focos que se compraron que
valen 2 pesos por lo tanto si tenemos x
focos que valen 2 pesos entonces tenemos
dos veces x focos que valen un peso el
doble de la cantidad de focos que valían
dos pesos muy bien y ahora utilizando
estos datos Cómo podemos expresar estos
600 pesos
yo sé que la cantidad de focos que valen
dos pesos déjame ponerlo por acá
la cantidad de focos que valen dos pesos
son x por lo que cuesta cada uno de
ellos es decir dos pesos más la cantidad
de focos que valen un peso es decir 2x
son estos de aquí 2x son estos de aquí
por lo que vale cada uno de estos focos
es decir por un peso eso tiene que ser
igual al total de dinero que me gasté
que son 600 pesos esto tiene que ser
igual a 600 pesos y de aquí ya podemos
obtener el valor de X 2x + 2x esto tiene
que ser igual a 600 pesos o dicho otra
manera 4x tiene que ser igual a 600
pesos que fue lo que me gasté x tiene
que ser igual a 600 entre 4 y cuánto es
esto Bueno pues esto es 150 es decir la
cantidad de focos la cantidad de focos
que valen dos pesos que compramos para
esta escuela son 150 voy a ponerlo aquí
la cantidad de focos que va pesos son
150 focos Ok y la cantidad de focos que
valen un peso Bueno pues es el doble de
esto es decir Son 300 focos que valen un
peso los que compramos para esta escuela
y si yo quiero saber la cantidad total
de focos que compramos para esta escuela
pues entonces habrá que sumar 150 + 300
lo cual me da 450 y ya tengo la
respuesta de este problema en esta
escuela se compraron
450 focos focos para sus instalaciones
así que ya está lo único que hicimos fue
un sistema de ecuaciones o mejor visto
de otra manera lo que hicimos fue
expresar la cantidad de focos que valían
un peso en relación a la cantidad de
focos que valían dos pesos bueno ya está
este problema creo que no estuvo tan
difícil y también sale por un sistema de
ecuaciones así que mejor veamos el
siguiente problema porque todavía
tenemos tiempo el problema número y
cambiamos de colores para no hacer esto
aburrido dice
cuatro veces x + y esto por x menos Y
esto es Exactamente igual a 40 y después
me dicen que x menos y x menos Y esto es
igual a 20 esto es igual a 20 y lo que
quieren saber es cuánto vale x + y
cuánto vale x + y muy bien pues lo
primero que se me ocurre hacer es
sustituir el valor de X - y este valor
justo acá arriba es decir voy a enchufar
x menos y aquí arriba con su valor de 20
y me va a quedar que 4 por x + y
esto a su vez por x menos y pero x menos
y vale 20 Entonces esto por 20 es igual
a 40 y ahora me va a quedar a 4 por 20
es 80 por x + y por x + y esto es igual
a 40 o dicho otra manera x + y es igual
a 40 entre 80 lo cual es un medio y es
justo la respuesta x + y = 1/2 que es lo
que me preguntaban x + y vale un medio
ya está problema 14 pues vamos a hacer
el problema número 15 Así que déjame
borrar la pantalla y vamos a hacer el
problema número 15 y me dice lo
siguiente si tenemos una circunferencia
cuyo centro cuyo centro Lo voy a poner
aquí el centro de esa circunferencia
está en el punto
5,12 es más déjame dibujarla tengo un
plano cartesiano tengo un plano
cartesiano por aquí Ok
perfecto y tengo mi otro eje por acá
Ok tengo mi otro eje por acá voy a decir
que este es el eje de las Yes Este es el
eje de las x y supongamos que aquí
estamos en el 5 y por acá estamos en el
12 OK Y entonces aquí está el centro de
mi circunferencia y me dicen además que
esta circunferencia toca solamente en un
punto al eje de las x eso es muy
importante vamos a intentar dibujarla
toca solamente en un punto al eje de las
x o sea que lo va a tocar más o menos
como por aquí y de hecho si te das
cuenta la única forma en que toque en
solo un punto al eje de las x es que
toque de manera tangente justo aquí
porque porque si nosotros hacemos crecer
más esta circunferencia va a cruzar en
dos puntos al eje de las x y tampoco
puede tocar al eje de las x por acá
arriba porque entonces este punto sería
negativo tendría una coordenada en y y
sabemos que el centro de este de esta
circunferencia es el punto 5,12 muy bien
utilizando que esta circunferencia tiene
como centro el punto 5,12 y además que
toca al eje de las x solamente en un
punto en este punto de aquí entonces lo
que me preguntan es cuánto vale su radio
Cuánto vale el radio de esta
circunferencia y bueno como nos podemos
tomar cualquier radio de hecho me gusta
tomarme más este radio Este es el radio
del cual yo me voy a fijar por qué
porque yo ya sé cuánto vale esta
distancia la distancia de aquí
acá cuánto vale Pues es lo que subimos
en y lo que subimos en Jet desde el eje
de las x pues son 12 unidades es decir
que de aquí Acá hay 12 unidades o dicho
otra manera el radio de esta
circunferencia son 12 unidades unidades
entonces Esta es
de mi problema número 15 Ya está no
estaba tan difícil Así que vamos a hacer
el problema número 16 borremos la
pantalla y pongamos Aquí el problema
número 16 bien Y en este problema
tenemos a una tabla una tabla parecida a
esta que dice hombres
hombres a mujeres
mujeres y por otra parte aquí arriba
tengo
a la población con edad de votar déjame
ponerlo aquí con edad Edad
de votar de votar y aquí tengo los
registrados los registrados Y qué datos
me dan Bueno me dicen que estos valen
1200 1200 estos valen 1000 estos valen
1000 Por otra parte Aquí tengo 1300 1300
y aquí tengo
1200 1200 Ok y me dicen que en la tabla
siguiente se muestran los datos del
registro de votantes del pueblo
bridgetown durante el actual Campaña en
la actualidad un 40% de la población con
edad de votar es decir un 40% de esta
población que tenemos aquí de la
población con edad de votar participó en
las elecciones solamente un 40% de ellos
un 40% de ellos participó en estas
elecciones
si el índice de participación de las
elecciones si el índice de la
participación de las elecciones vamos a
denotarlo con y el índice de la
participación de las elecciones está
dado por el número actual de votantes es
igual al número actual de votantes
actual
de votantes de votantes
dividido entre el número de votantes
registrados entre el número de votantes
registrados votantes registrados
registrados entonces lo que me preguntan
es Cuánto valen el índice de
participación de estas elecciones
pues bueno lo primero que vamos a hacer
es sacar Cuánto vale el 40% de la
cantidad de personas que tienen edad
para votar en este pueblo Y bueno pues
esto es 1.200 más 1.300 me da 2500 y yo
sé que solamente el 40% de estos 2500
votaron en estas elecciones Cuánto es el
40% de 2500 a ver 2500 y a esto lo voy a
multiplicar por el punto 4 y entonces me
quedan 25 por 4 es 100 100 y después hay
dos ceros más dos ceros más y hay que
recorrer el punto una vez recorremos el
punto una vez esto es lo mismo que mil
mil personas votaron en estas elecciones
mil personas es el número actual de
votantes ya esto Lo voy a dividir entre
la cantidad de votantes registrados que
esto es la suma de estos dos que es 2200
2.200 Y entonces a esto lo tengo que
dividir entre
2200 y yo quiero saber esta fracción de
aquí este 0 se puede ir con este cero
este cero se puede ir con este cero y
esencialmente me queda 10 entre 22 o lo
que es lo mismo podemos sacar mitad
arriba y me queda 5 y Mitad también
abajo y me queda 11 5 entre 11 Esta es
la fracción que me piden 5/11 el índice
de participación actual de estas
elecciones es 5/11 ya quedó Entonces
tengo el problema número 16 y ya no
tengo tiempo así que nos vemos en el
siguiente vídeo